[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est le match contre benneteau en
quatre points
attention j'arrête la folie si je perds
j'arrête l'émission pendant huit ans ils
ont des panneaux les salles au lido oui
c'est pas attention c'est parti à laval
parfois j'ai commencé à aller vous
servez vous êtes allés dans la boue la
matinée comme et il est con allez c'est
parti à 4 x 4 pour la tension ou la
vache mais bon on joue son petit
chouchou grave
[Applaudissements]
et toi non
je
est-ce que lors de vos nombreuses
visites d'appartement la propriétaire
vous demande également de la visite est
quoi battant oui je réponds oui
jamais jamais jamais jamais auteur ben
désolé je m'appelle par rocco siffredi
jamais il ya une rx 7
oui c'est vrai que j'aimerais coûtera
parents que ça c'est vrai elle a besoin
des plus rude qu'il a gelé visite jamais
les propriétaires
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
allez papa
oh non attention attention voilà bonne
voiture et si je perds tu fais quelque
chose si tu perds supporter le poids la
cdu perd ce poste 105 x 105 x 14 donne
tout mon coeur frustré
[Applaudissements]
c
mathieu bon assez scolaire est un nom se
doute l'atout en amour rien et bête on
n'est jamais ridicule tant qu'on est
sincère il n'a fait plus qui peut-être
dans ces deux grosses mon plaza tel un
appartement visite moi c'est pas mal ça
démarre le programme sur ces mots rien à
rénover à décorer fils trouvera
peut-être une pièce cachée ce qu'on
appelle la panic room ya une oppression
sur la vita tard
le les balles de match là non non elle
est tranquille on y va voilà allez c'est
pas ta petite maison à me conseiller
on se concentre au lam h une petite
maison est à la rue
la seule chose que tu auras à faire pour
trouver ton bonheur est de faire tomber
la cloison de mon coeur dabo partout
sauf à merde
merci et si tu cherches bien tu trouvera
peut-être la pièce avec poutres
apparentes
[Applaudissements]
ça laisse rêveur gfc bah écoutez les
années maintenant même si l'enjeu c'est
au sein de la famille
on l'appelle
et
à
défonce le
[Applaudissements]
on sait pas
la mesure des pages web avec la poste
appellent à une luxation comment t'as
fait ça
trente centimètres je comprends pas ils
coûteront donc je veux dire mabrouk
mabrouk allé comme on dit dans le milieu
qui salue une petite mexicaine et moi je
suis ton ami johnny mais c'est
aujourd'hui parce que je conduis ma
keller quand j'ai voulu prendre ma
douche 30 ans antoine mathieu
les livres à la racine vim
[Applaudissements]